Okay, so, let's see how this works.
Okay.
I will type in the
formula I'll calculate and then I'll try to
visually explain to you.
How it works.
Coming back to Wolfram Alpha.
This is the function.
For the standards know what distribution okay, what we
want to do is because this is not the whole
story.
We actually want to
integrate
this function
Okay.
So we want to integrate.
this function
Of course with respect to Z.
this function is going to give us the
the probability of a single
experiment
But if you want to take the acute the cumulative.
probability of a range of values
you have to integrate why integrate again.
Because we're dealing with continuous values. We will end
up with a curve distribution and if you want to measure this area, that's where
integration comes in.
So what I want to do is integrate.
From one standard from one negative standard deviation to
the positive standard deviation.
To see how we arrived at that
particular probability number.
So we actually want to integrate.
So what we'll do is going back to Wolfram.
Is we want to integrate you will now see if you
don't recognize latex. You will now see it's
The mathematical syntax now, we want to integrate from negative
Infinity from the left side of the probability distribution,
right since the probability distribution when it's
normalized will be shifted to zero and then towards
the left of zero, we have negative numbers obviously and then
positive that right. So what we want to do is we want to count accumulate from
the left so we go from negative Infinity.
two negative 1
the first standard deviation
Okay, and of course, we're driving integrating.
for Z
Let's hit equal and you'll see in mathematical
format.
Did I type it correctly?
No, did I leave something out infinity? And
this has to be here?
Yeah, there we go.
So
what has just happened?
What has happened if I go back to?
That normal distribution. Let me see if I can find one where we
have the numbers plotted. I'll find a
picture here.
No one will distribution.
Send it at zero.
Then we should have.
Yeah, this will do.
So what we have done?
What has just now happened?
Is we have calculated?
the area
Or come on now.
Yeah, what we have done just done is we
have integrated.
We have calculated the area.
all the way from negative Infinity up to negative 1
Okay, so we know.
the cumulative probability
of this region
Then what we will do.
is calculate
the
cumulative probability from negative Infinity all to
positive 1
We will then subtract it to.
And when we subtract the two we will then know. What is a
probability.
That the experiments will fall.
within one standard deviation
Okay. I hope that's clear other. If not,
we will revisit this idea again.
What we've done up to this point is we've calculated this part
now we need to continue.
positive one
then we will take that region the area of
that curve that portion of the curve subtracting subtracted
with this.
area of the curve to then
arrive at the the correct probability
the number
probability
So let's close this.
So first we go from
negative Infinity to negative one
that gives us 0.15.
And you know 0.158655. Is it
here is a listed on the example. Let's see.
Yes, there it is. Okay.
So this is how you do it.
five of negative 1
5 of 1 standard deviation towards the left gives you a
point 15.86 866 you integrate
this. So you integrate the five function.
And you arrive at this number? That's how we have.
0.158655
then we do it again, but we go all the way to
positive one
And naturally that's going to give us.
0.841 blah blah blah and then
you set like I said, you subtract these two, okay, but let's first finish
with
this idea
wherever yes, here we go. This is it. This
is how you do it.
So you integrate?
You integrate from negative Infinity up to
that standard deviation. Let's say if if this were
if you wanted to know if it falls within two two standard
deviations that you would go from negative Infinity to negative 2, and then
again from negative Infinity integrate from negative Infinity all the
way to positive two so objective to get your
To determine whether it falls within you know.
0.67 probably percent
probability 90 95% probably 99% probably
and so on.